[音楽]
[拍手]
はい皆さんこんばんは
えーとですね今日皆さんにこの質問から
スタートさせていただきたいと思うんです
けど皆さん今日
ランチ何食べました
和食ですか
夜食ですか
あるいは何も食べたいから
思いますじゃあその食べたメニュー
どうやって決めました
食べたいものを選びました
あるいはいつも食べてるものと同じものを
やりました
今日はですねこの皆さんの食のこのこれを
キーワードに皆さんの感情とかあるいは
行動原理
これをですね
微生物学の観点からお話したいなという
ふうに思います
最初に
この画像を見てください
皆さんどこに注目されます
だいたいここですよね
どんな
種類のワンちゃんかなとかオスから7歳
ぐらいかなってきっと思うと思うんです
でも私が
注目するのこっちなんですよ
はいペンです
あの実は私
大学生の頃このワンちゃんなんですね
散歩している人を見かけてはこんな風に声
かけてました
すいません
怪しいものじゃないんですけどその
袋の中に送りくれませんか
そうするとだいたいですね皆さん
ていう顔をされるんです
私はこの便の
研究をやってました
便利に含まれる成分の研究ある成分の勉強
しました皆さん
便にどんな成分が含まれるかご存知ですか
実は
円のだいたいですね70%から80%は
水分です
残り20%のうちの半分ぐらいに皆さんが
食べたもののうちの食べかすですねとか
腸の細胞が一番入ってます
でその残り半分が実は
腸内細菌という皆さんのお腹の中に住んで
いる微生物になります私はこの
腸内細菌の研究を大学生の頃からかれこれ
24年間ずっとやり続けてます
でこの腸内細菌なんですけど実は皆さん
一人の人間の中になんとですね40兆個も
いるん
ですものすごい数ですよ
ね実はこの人間っていうのは人間の細胞で
できているだけではなくて
腸内細菌をお腹の中にたくさんいる
人間の細胞と腸内細菌が合わさってできて
いる生き物スーパーオーガニックという風
に考えられ
ますこれはですね
地球をちょっと考えてみます
地球上には実は私たち人はですねだいたい
78億人住んでますこの78億人が
それぞれ各自が振る舞うことによってこの
地球というものに大きな影響を与えている
わけです
ただこの地球に対する人口よりも皆さん
一人に対する
腸内細菌の数の方がなんと5000倍以上
も多いのです
他に考えるとやはりこういった腸内細菌が
私たちの体で様々な影響を与えていると
いうことは容易に
想像がつくんじゃないかなと思います
じゃあこの腸内細菌何してるでしょうか
実はですね最近の研究でもいろんなことが
わかって
ます例えば私たちのお腹の中に住んでいる
腸内細菌が人間にとって必要なあるいは
大事な栄養素を作ってくれたりとか
あとは
睡眠の必要ですね
良くしてくれたりとかあとは
持久力
これは上げてくれる能力があるなんてこと
も実は私たちは研究でも分かってきてい
ますただそれだけじゃありません
実は
腸内細菌
私たち
の脳にも
影響するということは知られています実は
脳と
焦点は神経で繋がっていますまたホルモン
でもやり取りしますきっと皆さんのこんな
経験あるんじゃないかなと思います例えば
そうですね何か試験の前
ありがたく大きな大会の前ちょっと
緊張してお腹がゆるくなる
あるいは逆にちょっと
便秘になるこれは
脳がストレスを感知してそのシグナルが
腸に行って
腸の動きを変えることによって実はそう
いう状態になるとわかってますしあるいは
例えば皆さんがですね食べ放題のお店に
行ったとしましょう
めちゃくちゃたくさん食べますねきっとで
もある時もう食べられないって
なるわけですこれは実は
腸の中にたくさんの栄養素が入ってくるん
でそこから
腸からもう食べなくていいよってホルモン
が出てきて最終的には脳に作用して食べる
のを皆さんはやってるわけですつまり
脳と腸というのは密接にやり取りしてい
ますが実はそこにこの腸内細菌が大きな
影響を与えているということが近年のこと
がわかってきますですので自宅の腸内細菌
はそういった私たちの大きな影響を与える
ことによって例えば
こういうところに場外サイズが影響を与え
たりとか
さらには人のやる気モチベーションこう
いったところにはね実は
障害最近が影響を与える人ということが
わかってきていますちょっと実例ご紹介し
ますこれは動物実験のデータなんです
けれども様々な別々の3つの異なる環境で
生活していたネズミの
腸内細菌を取ってきてこれを同じ
環境で生活している
遺伝子も同じまず多治見この腸内細菌だけ
を移植するということが実験的にできます
で彼らの食の好みを調べた結果なんとです
ねこの左2つのグループは
ロープロテイン配管を入れるとこういう
タイプの餌をこのようになりました
一方一番右側のグループ右側のグループは
ハイプロテイン
ローカード全く逆の食事を好むようになり
ましたこのように実は
腸内細菌が違うことによってその
宿主の食の好みが
影響されるということが近年の研究で
分かってきています
もう一個
失礼ご紹介します
これもネズミを使った実験なんですけれど
もこのネズミに
抗生物質を与えて
腸内細菌をなくしてしまうそうするとなん
とですね運動
能力が低下したりとか運動する
モチベーションこれも下がってしまうと
いうこともわかってきました多分これを皆
さんご気軽にあるんじゃないかなと思うん
ですけれどもなんかこうやらなきゃいけ
ないことがあるんだけどちょっとやる気出
ない
安心してくださいこれ皆さんのせいじゃ
なくて
腸内細菌の可能性ありますただですねこれ
やる気がなくなったネズミ大丈夫です
やる気を復活させるやり方がありますどう
やるかこのネズミにやる気を持たせる腸内
細菌を入れると実はやる気が出る運動
パフォーマンスが上がりますし運動をやる
モチベーションも上がる
そんなバカだって皆さん思うかもしれませ
んけれども少なくとも動物実験がこれは
証明されていますそして皆さんも
身近にもきっとこんな方いらっしゃるん
じゃないかなと思うんですけれども例えば
一
卵性双生児
双子ですね特に遺伝的背景を一覧性
ソーセージどうでしょう彼らも例えばそう
ですね性格とか
あるいは好き嫌いあるいはいろんな能力
同じじゃないですよ
ね遺伝子が全く一緒にもかかわらずこう
いった人の多様性個性こういったところに
実は腸内細菌が
影響しているんじゃないかという風に考え
てきますしこれもちょっと私たちのデータ
をご紹介しますこれは25人の健康な
方たちの
腸内細菌調べたデータでこのボード1本1
本がある一人の人の腸内細菌です色の違い
は
腸内細菌を大まかに分類してこの色の違い
が腸内細菌の種類の違いを意味してい
ますそうするとこれ見てると分かる通り
みんな違うんですね一人として
腸内細菌の種類やバランスは同じくいない
ん
ですなので私たちのこういった
趣味嗜好であるとかあるいは
モチベーションとかあるいは個人の個性
ダイバーシティというものがこの腸内細菌
の違いによって紐付けられているんでは
ないかというふうに我々は考えています
なぜ
腸内細菌がこんなことを私たちの心に思考
やモチベーション行動に影響を与えている
のかここから私の仮説です
これは
腸内細菌にとっての生存戦略なんではない
かというふうに私は考えてます
どういうことかと言いますと
腸内細菌私たちのお腹の中にどうやって
住み着いているか実は
腸というのは
蠕動運動って言いまして動いてますそして
腸の中にはすでに便として排泄されてい
ますですので
腸内細菌が私たちのお腹の中にいる状態で
住みつくためには実は
排泄される速度よりも早くお腹の中で分裂
をして増えることによってその場に
生き残るという状態を作ってます
ランニングマシーンだけで走ってると一緒
ですねそうすることによって死体を動いて
ますから
常に自分がその場所にいられるという戦略
を取ってますじゃあどうやって
腸内細菌が私たちのお腹の中で増えるか
増殖するか彼らはに必要な栄養素つまり
私たちが食べたものが実は
腸内細菌の餌になる彼らそれを利用して
増えることによってその場に居続けている
ということをしているわけです
ですのでじゃあお腹の皆さんのお腹の中に
いる腸内細菌やこの場にいようとしたら
やっぱり人間に自分たちが必要な栄養素を
食べてもらわなきゃいけないんですね
なので実は私皆さんがこうランチに
メニューを選んだと思うんですその
選択基準が自分が選んでいるように考える
実は腸内細菌が選ばせているのかもしれ
ない
きっと皆さんもこんな経験あるんじゃない
かなと思います
例えばそうですね大学生あるいは社会人に
なった時に親元を離れて
一人暮らしを始める
そうするとなんとなくこのお袋の味が
恋しくなるとか
つなげてありません
あるいは皆さん例えば日本で生活していて
何かにかける海外に例えば仕事で海外に
赴任するとなるでしばらくいるとなんと
なく和食が食べたくなる
これはちょっと皆さんは自分の意志でこれ
を食べようと和食を食べようと思っている
のかもしれませんが実はこれが
腸内細菌によって
選ばされているのかもしれない彼らはこの
ように人に食べ物を選ばせることで
腸内細菌やお腹の中に自分たちの菌がご
存在できるような状態を作っているんでは
ないかというふうに我々は考えています
これを
言葉で考えると実はお腹とそれから感情と
かあるいは
意思決定にかかる言葉って日本にも
たくさんあるんですそうですね例えば
腹に据えるとか
腹が立つとかこれ怒りの方ですよね
あるいは花を決めるとか
腹をくくるとかこれ意思決定ですよねなぜ
人は頭で考えていると思っているにも
関わらずお腹にまつわる言葉で表現されて
いる
これはもしかすると
昔から実はこっちじゃなくてこっちが本体
でいろんな感情であるとか
意思決定行動権というものが決まっている
んじゃないかということを実は経験的に
知っていたのかもしれません
最後にですねもう1回この写真皆さん見て
ください
どこに注目します
いやわかってます分かってますまだワン
ちゃんですよねはいわかってますただこの
袋の中にある
例の中にはきっと皆さんの行動原理これが
隠されてるんじゃないかなというふうに私
は思ってますそれから最後一つずつ今日皆
さんにお願いがあります
もし皆さんが今後ワンちゃんの
散歩をしている時に
もしその
袋の中身をくださいと
誰かに言われたら
訝しがらずに分かってますよと一言言って
あげてくださいそうなんです今日私はです
ねこの場に
未来の
腸内細菌研究者のためにこれを伝えにこの
場にやってきたんですがただこの行動自体
もきっと私じゃなく私の腸内細菌がそうさ
せたくないと思っております以上です
ありがとうございました
[拍手]